[Music]
the picture that you see on your screen
is of a person named Louis Braille at
the age of three he had injured his eyes
leaving him completely blind yes he
sadly lost his sense of vision being a
bright and inquisitive child he
continued his education and invented an
interesting system which is today known
as the Braille system this is the system
for visually handicapped people as it
helps them to read and write
let us study more about the system this
basic structure of the system starts
with the Braille cell as you can see
it's a cell with six dots arranged in
three rows and two columns these cells
are named as one two three from top to
bottom on the left and four five six
from top to bottom on the right now on a
piece of paper some or all of these dots
are slightly raised about their position
this is for the visually handicapped
people to feel these dots using their
sense of touch so this was just one
Braille cell there are many on the piece
of paper that can be used to form long
sentences and numbers the dot height
cell size and cell spacing are uniform
throughout coming back to the single
cell how many patterns do you think can
be formed from one single cell this can
be one pattern this can be another this
is one more and so on how many patterns
do you think can be formed there are a
total of 63 dot patterns that can be
formed if we assume no dots raised to be
one pattern then sixty-four patterns can
be formed each dot pattern can represent
letters combination of letters a full
word or some symbol here is the list of
the combination of dots representing the
things mentioned above for example the
letter A is represented by this cell
only the first dot is raised in this
case similarly the letter J
is represented by this but these three
dots raised the dots two four and five
are raised so this is the set of
patterns we have for the English
alphabet 26 such patterns but now I want
you to observe something interesting
look at the pattern for the digit one
and the letter A aren't they the same
how does the visually handicapped person
know whether it's an A or one for that
look at this pattern which says number
follows when we have this pattern in
front of a pattern it tells us that a
number follows so this here tells us
that we are talking about the digit 1
and not the letter A similarly this
would be the digit 2 and so on
why do we need to have these preceding
pattern why can't we just have different
patterns for numbers that's because we
have limited patterns only 64 if you
remember so just with this one pattern
of number follows we saved 10 more
patterns for the digits 0 to 9 we also
have patterns for punctuation and signs
you can see that this cell represents
the question mark sign
whereas this cell represents plus sign
Braille system is the most popular
system for the visually challenged
people used across the world Braille
text can be produced by hand or nowadays
it is produced using specific
typewriters as well
[Music]
you